with coronavirus officially hitting all
50 states in the country it's nearly as
ubiquitous as influenza but unlike the
flu coronavirus hasn't killed nearly as
many people in 2018 the flu caused 61
thousand deaths in the US as of this
video corona virus has killed less than
300 in what ways are these viruses
similar but also different and is
coronavirus more deadly than the flu
firstly let's look at the history of
both the flu and corona virus the flu
more specifically influenza A has been
around for more than 2,500 years with
records as early as ancient Greece from
Hippocrates it's been responsible for
most human pandemics in history with the
most recent being the 1918 Spanish flu
due to it being around for so long
humans have built up an immunity over
numerous generations influenza A is
known to infect birds and mammals and
it's believed that the virus is
transmitted from wild aquatic birds to
domesticated poultry and then to humans
the actual virus responsible for the
corona virus pandemic is called the SARS
Cove - virus which stands for severe
acute respiratory syndrome coronavirus -
when compared to the flu it's extremely
young with its first transition to
humans being just 4 months ago
since it's so new humans have not built
up an immunity to it making a
potentially deadly er the SARS Cove -
virus is part of the corona virus family
that in fact spats and is very similar
to the Tsarskoe virus of 2003 the World
Health Organization believes the
horseshoe bat was the original reservoir
for it and it was in December that the
virus was spread from bad to human but
the mode of transmission has not yet
been determined both viruses come from
different viral families influenza A
comes from the ortho Nixle Verde family
while Sarah's Cove 2 is native to the
corona Verde family Corona verde gets
its name due to the petal shape proteins
on the virus's surface structurally the
viruses are very similar both are
spherical in shape
however SARS Cove 2 tends to be slightly
larger at 125 nanometers in diameter
whereas influenza A is about 100
nanometers both are coated in a lipid
envelope have an
eternal capsid and our RNA viruses
meaning they use their RNA to infect the
host to replicate more viruses the
infection and replication cycle of
influenza A goes like this it first
binds to the silac acid receptor on the
surface of epithelial cells located in
the nose throat in lungs from inhaling
respiratory droplets the virus is then
absorbed into the cell cytoplasm where
the acidic conditions disassemble the
capsid releasing viral RNA the RNA is
then transported into the cell nucleus
where complementary RNA is made and as
an exported back out into the cytoplasm
viral proteins are synthesized and
assembled into new variants the new
viruses cluster into a bulge in the cell
membrane and eventually bud off in a
phospholipid sphere made of the cell's
own membrane to infect other cells thus
Aris Cove 2 virus infects cells a little
bit differently the virus has spike
proteins that attach to the h2 receptor
on the surface of the host cell studies
have shown that SARS co2 has a higher
affinity to this receptor than the
previous SARS virus from 2003 meaning it
has a stronger attachment to the
receptor explaining why it's more
infectious after attaching an adjacent
enzyme to the receptor cuts open the
spike protein releasing the RNA into the
cell the viral RNA is synthesized into
proteins in the cytoplasm and is then
transported to the cell's endoplasmic
reticulum where they're assembled into
new viruses the new viruses are then
transported out of the cell by secretory
vesicles where they infect other cells
both viruses share similar symptoms like
fever dry cough and sore throat
however with corona virus upper
respiratory symptoms like runny nose and
sinus congestion are not common and less
than 45% of patients have fatigue or
muscle aches
in contrast the flu has all of these
symptoms the flus onset of symptoms
appear after about two days whereas
coronaviruses onset is 1 to 14 days with
the median being 5 thereby allowing an
infected person to spread it unknowingly
which is why the social distancing is so
stressed
transmission for flu and coronavirus are
identical the most common transmission
method being airborne respiratory
droplets from coughing or sneezing into
the eyes nose or mouth of another person
the rains that aerosol particles can
travel from a sneeze is about six feet
and can carry as much as 40,000
respiratory droplets which is why the
CDC recommends this length for social
distancing the other form of
transmission is the physical placement
of viral particles from your hand to
your eyes nose and mouth by yes touching
your face flu activity begins in October
increases in December and Peaks in
February because the flu and coronavirus
are similar viruses in their structure
method of infection and replication they
should both react to environmental
changes in the same way the noticeable
drop in flu activity in March and April
are due to an increase in temperature
and humidity in 2007 microbiologist
Peter police tested to see if there was
a correlation between high temperature
high humidity and the rate of survival
for the flu virus he found that with
conditions at 43 degrees Fahrenheit and
low humidity the virus was viable up to
23 hours at ninety degrees Fahrenheit in
high humidity the flu lasted less than
one hour a 2014 study from the Journal
of virology theorized why these
conditions make viruses less effective
firstly whether it's viruses human cells
or bacteria low temperatures always
reduce biological activity this is why
the food in your fridge perishes at a
slower rate than if you left it out at
room temperature it's believed that the
cold air passing through your Airways
reduces the enzyme activity in your
immune cells thereby decreasing their
defense against viruses that are inhaled
in your mouth nose and lungs secondly
lower humidity is believed to increase
infection rates due to the lower
presence of water in the air the flu is
predominantly spread by airborne
respiratory droplets larger droplets
spend less time in the air whereas
smaller droplets are airborne for longer
with less humidity in the air water from
the droplets actually evaporates off
faster thereby reducing the size of the
respiratory droplets this causes them to
stay airborne for longer increasing the
likelihood of a
hailing them influenza is usually self
resolving with rest liquids in the
occasional pill for muscle aches and
fever if you're immunocompromised or
elderly influenza can be treated with
antivirals and there's also a vaccine
although it only reduces your chances by
about 16 to 20 percent coronavirus as
far as we can tell is also self
resolving with the same treatments of
fluid and rest however because it's a
brand new virus to humans there is no
antivirals or vaccinations to treat it
and may even take years to produce this
is why the immunocompromised and elderly
are the most fatal targets finally this
brings us to the most controversial
comparison between corona virus and the
flu mortality rates influenza infect
nearly 1 billion people worldwide
resulting in 650 thousand deaths corona
virus has only caused about 16,000
deaths worldwide so why is it believed
to be deadlier well for two reasons
death rate and the basic reproduction
number influenza has a fairly low death
rate of 0.1 percent whereas the World
Health Organization estimates
coronavirus to be between 3 & 4 percent
for comparison the 1918 Spanish flu had
a death rate of 2.5% more people die
from the flu because more people are
infected if the rate of infections were
lower the death count would also be
lower this is the case with corona virus
at the moment the death count is still
low because the total number of
infections are also low
the second factor contributing to the
seriousness of corona virus is the basic
reproduction number or are not the basic
reproduction number estimates the
expected number of cases caused by one
case in a population where all
individuals are susceptible to infection
are not is not a constant for a pathogen
and is also affected by other factors
such as environmental conditions in the
behavior of the infected population this
means if infected people stay home don't
socialize and call their doctor or
hospital instead of going in person the
basic reproduction number will decrease
the are not value for influenza is 1.3
while for corona virus it's about 2.5
nearly double that of influenza this
number can
but is entirely dependent on how people
behave with social distancing and
quarantine rules according to the CDC if
the u.s. did nothing to counter the
virus pandemic basically if we all went
on as normal with working and
socializing the infections are predicted
to reach over 400,000 we won't hit
400,000 but we could get close if we
don't follow the CDC guidelines
so remember to maintain social
distancing and don't touch your face if
your city has enacted quarantine stay
inside finally if you feel sick and have
these symptoms don't physically go to
the doctor or the emergency room track
your symptoms and fever call the
hospital don't go in person I'm adding a
link in the description where you can
view real-time data of the spread of
copán 19 around the world thanks at
Johns Hopkins University we are going to
get through this thanks for watching and
stay safe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]